hey guys I'm Nietzsche and today I'm
gonna be reviewing the mac and cheese
maker I'm gonna be seeing if it works if
the mac and cheese tastes good and if
it's worth buying
I am super obsessed with mac and cheese
it is my absolute favorite food so the
stakes are really high for this one it's
extremely light which always gives me a
little bit of hesitation it says on the
backs here that it's a quicker way to
prepare mac and cheese it probably takes
like 15 minutes maybe to make like a box
mac and cheese on the stove so we'll see
if this is quicker than 15 minutes this
is supposed to be an all-in-one mac and
cheese maker I'm pretty sure like when I
make like box mac and cheese and the pot
that I use is all in one but completely
electric which is great you don't need a
stove perfect mac and cheese nation was
apparently established in 1995 I don't
know what or where that is but I'm
pretty sure I fit the qualifications to
be a member and mac and cheese nation so
holler at me also right here on the
bottom everything is better with cheese
and that is not a lot so far this
product is speaking truths to me it's
talking to my soul and I'm feeling
really good about it let's open it up
and see what's inside I'm really bad at
opening things just like my heart
great we've got instructions which is
always important this thing is so
extremely light like it just does not
feel durable at all but I guess you
don't need a lot of weight to make mac
and cheese this is our stirring knob
this is kind of like a fun thing to play
with like a fidget spinner or something
we've got three settings here for you to
put it on low simmer and boil this right
here is our ingredient slot and cap
we've got our built in strainer which is
great this is what they call a handle
very glad that they pointed that out to
me we've got a heating element here this
is how we heat it we've got almost two
full pages of warnings you definitely
want to be cautious and you definitely
want to be careful but a little alarming
that you have to be this careful so
there are a couple of recipes in the
back of this for a home a mac and cheese
bacon mac and cheese and store-bought
mac and cheese we're gonna go with the
store-bought mac and cheese because if
you're buying this product you're
probably looking for something simple
and quick and that is the simplest and
quickest option so I'm gonna go watch
this thing get my ingredients and then
we'll get to making mac and cheese okay
so I clean this thing you can't put it
in a dishwasher or submerge it into
water but you just have to wipe it down
with a you know soap and water looks
like there's a nonstick coating on the
bottom seems like it's simple enough to
clean but we'll see how easy it is once
we actually make our mac and cheese
we've got like our little mini spatula
here which i think is actually super
cute so I guess that's where they're
coming in with our one pot goodness you
don't even need a spoon or spatula to
stir it because all right little
starting our little stirring handle
already has that covered so I put just
under three cups of water in here it
says do not overfill it or the water
will boil over but there is a max feel
line in here so you can tale easily you
know how much water is too much we're
gonna put our ingredient cap back on now
that we have our water in we're already
on low so we're just gonna turn our
knotch
up to boil here it says that it should
take about six to seven minutes for it
to start boiling so we're just gonna
wait and see what happens it's been 30
minutes and not only is our water not
boiling but it's literally code
yeah like it's we changed the plug
I even tried so I turn it to simmer I
don't know what you guys want to do
because this is literally not working
like and this is supposed to be the
freakin quick one so either way this
thing's getting a F even if it were to
start working right now I want mac and
cheese though like I'm not leaving until
I get mac and cheese I I'm down mac and
cheese nation has supremely let me down
because that gadget did not work but I
still want my mac and cheese so I'm
gonna show you guys how to make it one
pot and I can cheese recipe that
actually will work we're going to start
with five cups of milk here we're gonna
bring it up to a simmer okay so my milk
has reached a simmer I'm gonna add my
pasta now now that we've simmer it down
I'm not in a rage as much and I'm just
gonna let this cook until it's tender I
know this isn't the video that you
thought you want it but this is the
video that you need so my pasta is all
cooks I'm gonna turn off the heat I'm
gonna add my cheese my butter salt and
pepper and I'm just gonna mix it until
it's nice and luxurious the one thing
our failed gadget did get right is that
cheese makes everything better and I'm
feeling a lot better now that I'm
finally putting cheese - macaroni this
is not the greatest sound ever my mac
and cheese is looking great now let's uh
put this in the bowl and taste it ah
cheese we're gonna add some parsley just
for garnish just so we can get a little
fancy that's beautiful look at those
colors guys I love it we have now made
it fancy and now all this look this will
give this thing a taste mmm that's what
I'm looking for right there nice cheesy
creamy delicious flavorful mac and
cheese that's what I need in my life
that's a to need in your life
that's a tuning in your life that's what
you know you're right here that's what
you need in your life I feel like my
energy level is just skyrocketed because
this is so absolutely delicious mac and
cheese maker unfortunately you get two
thumbs down from me
because you didn't even work but this
back and cheese gets to thumbs up so if
you guys have any gadgets that you want
us to try let us know in the comments
below if they don't work we will make it
work until then I'll see you guys later
oh yes
[Music]
you